Десь є людина, яка могла б урятувати йому життя.
Томасу де Ніро терміново потрібен донорський орган.
14 років тому йому вже зробили пересадку нирок.
Тоді німець уже жив на Майорці і отримав орган
одного померлого.
- Просто пощастило, коли людина виїжджає
в іншу країну, як я це зробив у 2001 році,
а 2 роки потому відмовляють нирки, і ти перебуваєш
саме в тій країні, де можна отримати нирку
в 4-5 разів швидше, ніж у Німеччині.
Тепер чоловік теж сподівається
швидко отримати нирку. Шанси непогані,
адже ніде у світі так багато людей не жертвують
свої органи після смерті, як в Іспанії. Тут,
за законом, кожен - потенційний донор,
якщо людина заздалегідь не оскаржила це.
Державна координація вважається зразковою.
Поки що Томас де Ніро повинен щодня
проходити процедуру перитонеального діалізу,
яка триває годинами. Це дуже сковує життя
60-річного чоловіка. Оскільки він живе в Іспанії,
йому доведеться чекати на нову нирку
близько двох років. У Німеччині це було б 8.
Чимало німців стали в чергу в Іспанії.
Іноді - в не дуже чесний спосіб.
- Дехто для цього лише реєструється в Іспанії.
Я знаю двох-трьох, які лише роблять вигляд,
що проживають тут. Купили будинок,
зареєстрували фірму. Усе по мінімуму, аби лише
знайти лазівку до іспанської медичної системи.
Мігель Анхель Феріоль вбачає в цьому проблему.
Він іспанець. Чоловік також отримав
донорський орган. Майже 10 років тому
йому зробили пересадку печінки. Нині він
цілком здоровий завдяки готовності
його співгромадян до донорства.
- Уявити собі не міг би чекати роками. Я знаю, що це
за очікування. Це не життя. У моєму випадку
все сталося швидко.
Мігель може зрозуміти німців, які переїжджають
в Іспанію заради трансплантації. Утім,
такі "трансплантаційні туристи" створюють
конкуренцію місцевим жителям
і ті мусять чекати довше.
- Іспанці жертвують органи для людей, які живуть
в Іспанії. Звісно, ми знаємо, що орган - чи то печінку,
чи нирку, - відправлять в інше місце, якщо тут
не буде в них потреби. Але якщо дедалі більше
людей приїздитимуть сюди по трансплантацію,
це треба буде припинити. Це ж логічно.
Так званий "трансплантаційний туризм"
у Євросоюзі заборонений. Утім, його
важко контролювати. В університетській клініці
в Пальмі пересаджують нирки.
Головний лікар з трансплантації мав серед пацієнтів
багато німців. Як лікар він повинен допомагати усім,
каже чоловік, і він не може встановити,
чи іноземець справді живе в Іспанії, чи приїхав
заради трансплантації.
- В ЄС вільне пересування. Дуже важко визначити,
чи людина справді тут живе. Потрібно, щоб це
врегулювало відомство з охорони здоров'я.
Воно має дбати дбати про порядок та встановити чіткі критерії.
Тиск на чиновників зростає.
Відомство з питань трансплантації при міністерстві
охорони здоров'я Іспанії розробляє критерії
для іноземних пацієнтів. У майбутньому в чергу
на органи зможуть ставати лише ті пацієнти, які
прожили в Іспанії щонайменше 2 роки.
- Треба розбиратися в ситуації детальніше.
Створити видимість життя в Іспанії можуть
собі дозволити лише люди, які мають гроші.
Інші повинні чекати у своїй країні на донорський орган.
Томас де Ніро не розуміє, чому в такій розвинутій
у галузі медицини країні, як Німеччина,
так мало донорських органів. Винні в цьому
недостатня координація та закон, відповідно
до якого від кожної людини потрібна окрема згода
на донорство.
- Це просто катастрофа, що люди з Німеччини
через таке дурне законодавство, яке необхідно
змінити, вимушені їхати за кордон аж до Індії,
щоб отримати орган, бо не можуть зробити це в Німеччині.
Томас де Ніро щасливий, що в Іспанії все інакше.
Тут кожен - потенційний донор, навіть громадянин
іншої країни, який помер на території Іспанії.
Тож навіть якийсь німецький турист
міг би врятувати його життя.